ya hemos aprendido acerca de suma de
matrices resta de matrices
multiplicación de matrices por lo que
quizás te estés preguntando si hay un
equivalente a la división de matrices
pero antes de que veamos eso déjame
introducir algunos conceptos y después
veremos que hay algo parecido no es
exactamente pero es análogo a la
división de matrices así que antes de
que hagamos eso voy a introducir el
concepto de la matriz identidad así que
la matriz identidad es una matriz la voy
a denotar por la letra i mayúscula y es
una matriz tal que cuando ya lo
multiplicó por otra matriz digamos la
matriz
y no sé si deba usar este punto aquí
pero bueno cuando multiplico la matriz
ciencia por la matriz a obtengo la misma
matriz de la misma manera si multiplico
a por la matriz y también voy a obtener
la misma matriz a y es importante darnos
cuenta que cuando hacemos multiplicación
de matrices importa el orden de hecho
aquí te estoy dando más información no
podemos suponer como pasaba en la
multiplicación regular que cuando
multiplicamos a por d es siempre igual a
multiplicar b por a es importante cuando
estamos haciendo multiplicación de
matrices verificar que importa el orden
en el cual estamos haciendo la
multiplicación en fin esto de aquí
funciona en ambos sentidos solo si
estamos tratando sólo si estamos
tratando con matrices cuadradas esto va
a funcionar en un sentido o en otro si
esta matriz no es cuadrada pero no va a
funcionar en ambos y puedes recordar por
qué pasa eso de cuando aprendimos
multiplicación de matrices en fin he
definido esta matriz ahora bien en qué
consiste esta matriz de hecho es
bastante simple
por ejemplo la matriz identidad de 2 por
2 es la matriz que consiste en 1
001 la matriz identidad de 3 por 3 es la
matriz 1 0 0 0 1 0 0 0 1 aquí ya estamos
viendo un patrón si creamos la matriz
identidad de 4x4 esta es 1 0 0 0 0 1 0 0
0 0 1 0 0 0 0 1 como puedes ver la
matriz identidad lo que es para
cualquier n esto lo puedes extender para
cualquier matriz de n por n consiste de
unos a lo largo de esta que es la
diagonal principal y los demás elementos
son 0 así que una vez dicho esto
probemos que esto realmente funciona
tomemos esta matriz y vamos a
multiplicar la por cualquier otra matriz
para confirmar que esa matriz no cambia
tomemos entonces la matriz 1 0 0 1
tomemos una matriz en general para que
veamos que funciona para cualesquiera
números
b c d y esto a que es igual vamos a
multiplicar
primero este este renglón por esta
columna 1 por 0 por c es igual a luego
este renglón por esta columna 1 por d +
0 por d es igual a d luego este renglón
por esta columna 0 por a más 1 por c es
igual a c finalmente este renglón por
esta columna 0 por b más uno por d es
igual a de ahí lo tenemos y puede ser un
ejercicio divertido hacerlo en el otro
sentido de hecho un mejor ejercicio es
probar esto para una matriz de 3 x 3
verás que también funciona y un muy buen
ejercicio para ti es pensar porque esto
es así y si te fijas bien es porque
estás obteniendo la información del
renglón de aquí la información de la
columna de aquí básicamente cada que
multiplicas digamos este vector por este
vector de aquí estás multiplicando los
términos correspondientes y después los
está sumando correcto aquí tenemos un 1
y un 0 el 0 cancela todo excepto el
primer término el vector columna por eso
que nos resulta también aquí cancela
todo excepto el primer término el vector
columna
resulta ver lo mismo aquí pero en este
caso sólo dejar el segundo término por
eso resulta aquí se esto por esto es
igual hace y esto por esto es igual a de
y lo mismo aplica para matrices de tres
por tres o matrices de n por en esto de
las matrices inversas es realmente
interesante completamos nuestra analogía
pensemos en esto en matemáticas
normalmente tenemos que uno por a es
igual a a y también qué
1 entre ahora y esto es matemáticas
normal nada que ver con matrices esto es
igual a 1 y como sabes llamamos a este
el inverso de a que lo mismo que está
dividiendo entre el número a entonces
existe una analogía en matrices déjame
cambiar de color he estado usando mucho
el color verde existe entonces una
matriz una matriz que si yo la
multiplicó por la matriz a llamemos de
la inversa de a la cual si yo la
multiplicó por la matriz a obtengamos no
el número uno sino el equivalente en
matrices que es la matriz identidad y
estaría perfecto si pudiéramos invertir
el orden del producto es decir si
multiplicó a por la inversa de a obtenga
también la matriz identidad y si lo
piensas bien si ambas de éstas se
cumplen entonces no tan sólo hay inversa
es inversa de a sino que a es inversa de
a inversa lo que quiero decir es que
ambas son inversas mutuamente y resulta
que si existe esa matriz se llama la
matriz inversa de a como ya lo he
mencionado 3
y ahora te voy a mostrar cómo calcularla
hagamos eso y nos daremos cuenta que
calcularlo para matrices de 2 por 2 es
bastante simple aunque quizás pienses
que es un poco misterioso en cómo la
gente llegó a la mecánica del cálculo o
el algoritmo de esto 3 x 3 es un poquito
más complicado 4 x 4 te llevará todo el
día y una de 5 x 5 definitivamente va a
incurrir en muchos errores si la haces a
mano lo aconsejable es calcular inversas
de 5 por 5 en una computadora en fin
cómo calculamos la inversa de una matriz
hagamos eso y después verifiquemos que
realmente la inversa entonces si tenemos
una matriz a dada por
b c y d y quiero calcular su inversa su
inversa va a ser y ahorita por lo pronto
te va a parecer como que sacada de la
manga en futuros vídeos te va a dar un
poco de la intuición acerca de esto de
hecho te mostraré cómo se obtiene por lo
pronto lo mejor será que memorice los
pasos para que así tengas la confianza
de saber cómo puedes calcular un inversa
esto es igual a 1 sobre el producto de
estos números a por de menos b por c
d - bc y esta cantidad de aquí a d - bc
vamos a aprender bueno de hecho de una
vez podemos mencionar que se llama el
determinante de la matriz a y esto lo
vamos a multiplicar es un escalar es un
número lo vamos a multiplicar por la
matriz que resulta vamos a intercambiar
a y de los elementos de la diagonal
principal sería de i a iii estos dos
números de la parte inferior izquierda
en la parte superior derecha les vamos a
cambiar el signo nos quedaría menos c y
menos b y el determinante y de nueva
cuenta éste se lo que vas a tener que
creerme por el momento en futuros vídeos
te prometo explicar temas en torno a
esto de hecho es un poco complicado
explicar cómo se construye un
determinante en las clases de prepa tec
en que la prendas de memoria eso es algo
con lo que yo no estoy de acuerdo
entonces qué es esto esto también se
llama el determinante de a quizás te lo
puedan preguntar un examen y se denota
de manera similar a como denotamos el
valor absoluto esto es determinante de a
y es igual a d
- abc así que aquí tenemos uno sobre el
determinante de a por lo cual la inversa
de a es igual a 1 sobre determinante de
a que multiplica la matriz cuyos
elementos son de menos ve menos a como
quiera que lo veas pero apliquemos esto
un problema real para que veas que no es
tan difícil cambiamos letras para que
sepas que no siempre tiene que ser una
digamos que sea la matriz b igual
digamos 3 estoy tomando números al azar
menos 4
- 5 calculemos entonces la inversa debe
la inversa debe está dada por uno sobre
el determinante debe que es 3 x menos 5
menos 2 por menos 43 x menos 5 es menos
15 y 2 x menos 4 es menos 8 pero al
restar lo obtenemos más 8
y esto multiplicado por esto lo vamos a
multiplicar x
la matriz
cuyos elementos son intercambiamos los
elementos de la diagonal principal sería
menos 5 3 y luego cambiamos el signo a
estos elementos menos 24 era menos 4
cambiando el signo es 4
veamos si puedo simplificar esto un poco
la inversa
dv va a ser igual menos 15 8 es menos 7
entonces esto resulta menos 1 sobre 7 el
determinante es menos 7 vamos a ponerlo
por aquí el determinante de b es igual a
menos 7 así que esto es igual a menos un
séptimo que multiplica a menos 54 menos
23 y esto es igual a menos un séptimo es
un escalar podemos multiplicarlo por
cada uno de los elementos de la matriz
entonces va a ser igual a menos 5 x
menos un séptimo sería cinco séptimos
menos un séptimo por 4 menos 4 séptimos
menos 2 por menos un séptimo sería dos
séptimos y finalmente menos un séptimo
por tres menos tres
séptimos está un poco peliaguda esta
matriz acabamos con fracciones y cosas
así pero confirmemos que ésta realmente
es la inversa de la matriz b hagamos la
multiplicación para eso voy a necesitar
un poco de espacio por acá voy a borrar
esto
volvemos acá también
hagamos espacio estoy aquí tampoco lo va
a necesitar
perfecto estamos listos confirmemos que
esto x esto o esto x esto de acá resulta
en la matriz identidad
hagamos lo voy a cambiar de color b
inversa es vamos a ponerla por aquí
cinco séptimos espero que no haya hecho
errores menos cuatro séptimos
2 séptimos
y menos 3 séptimos ese nivel se debe voy
a multiplicar la por ver qué es
3 - 42 menos 5 y eso es igual a
vamos a ponerla por acá necesito espacio
para hacer mis cálculos déjame cambiar
color nuevamente entonces vamos a
multiplicar este renglón por esta
columna entonces que tenemos cinco
séptimos por tres es tres por cinco
séptimos es 15 séptimos
más o menos cuatro séptimos por dos
menos cuatro séptimos por dos es menos
déjame asegurarme de esto cinco séptimos
por 315 séptimos menos cuatro séptimos
poderoso chelsea está correcto entonces
sería menos cuatro séptimos por dos en
los cuatro céntimos por dos es menos 8
séptimos aunque si está perfecto
ahora vamos a multiplicar este renglón
por esta columna de acá que tenemos aquí
cinco séptimos por menos cuatro es menos
20 séptimos y luego menos 4 séptimos por
menos 5 que tenemos aquí sería 20
séptimos positivo entonces tenemos que
sumarle 20 séptimos más 20 séptimos
mi mente se ha alentado un poco haciendo
multiplicaciones con fracciones y
números negativos pero este es muy buen
ejercicio para varias partes del cerebro
en fin hagamos este término de aquí
vamos a multiplicar entonces este
renglón por esta columna dos séptimos
por 36 séptimos más menos 3 séptimos por